[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey welcome back to the break room
everybody uh it's the nerdy news show
you need to know live from New rockstars
headquarters here uh you know what it's
an all Ant-Man episode today we're still
talking about that trailer from last
night it's all we could talk about and
so it's all we're going to talk about in
this episode uh with me to do that we've
got Brandon Barrick we've got Tommy
bechtold over here what is this a show
for ants okay and in between them we've
got the birthday girl
happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
[Music]
oh
okay and uh it's your birthday oh okay
Tommy uh real quick we uh we're gonna
try to get to all super chats if you're
if you Super Chat us a question about
the quantumania trailer we're gonna try
to answer all of your comments what are
your thoughts or your takes or your
prayers your prayers or just compliment
our fits yeah thank you
thank you as always to calls uh but
let's get right into it because we're so
excited to talk about all the lingering
threads left over from that trailer
let's get into the headlines yes
meetings and all of the headlinis today
are about Ant-Man Ant-Man because in
addition to a trailer you read a little
bit of this on yesterday's episode but
we got a big press release that actually
gave us a lot of important interesting
information we did not already know yeah
spelled out like some character
descriptions lots of quotes from The
Producers the actors the director it was
very interesting yeah we also got along
with that press release that we'll get
into in a second we got two new posters
for the movie there's one gorgeous so
stylish does that love those colors
don't let your partner say that's not
appropriate for company oh
okay why is hoping the front oh hope is
in direct front
uh both those very attractive posters I
like the more stylized kind of helmet me
too one but that the the second one is
kind of that's that classic Marvel look
where you get all the characters in
there and uh doing their superhero poses
okay and then uh and real quick later in
the show we're gonna have a very
interesting display of Art
yeah I'll leave it like a threat you
will want to stick around to the end of
this episode okay
um but we got some small details about
what the plot might look like this is
according to Disney right uh according
to the press release the quantum realm
will already be at War by the time Hank
Janet Scott hope and Cassie arrive uh
we'll come back to that in a second here
uh but that's interesting and that kind
of like jives with we see these kind of
like in the first trailer we saw this
kind of warrior looking characters the
glow head guy different characters kind
of show up with armor and and Quantum
Maniacs I call them whoa because like
Animaniacs they're trapped
that's that's right and they don't get
fed oh uh hope is uh so this is outside
of the quantum realm uh the movie starts
hope is now the leader of the Pim Van
Dyne foundation and she's utilizing the
pin particle to advance humanitarian
efforts uh and and people have
speculated that's probably why we see
hope and Scott kind of showing up at the
gala uh in the trailer in their fancy
outfits I think from thank you for
making rice so big I know one giant one
piece of rice can feed a whole country
of course that's true I also that's a
good observation because I immediately
was like oh they're there for his book
yeah or his podcast right yeah and
hilariously we were working on the
breakdown of the trailer after we did
our live stream last night and uh the
it's like the global humanitarian
Service Awards and it's a perfect
amalgamation of like three actual real
life awards that are like the global
Service Awards the global humanitarian
Awards the service global awards like so
this is I believe a fictional award
they're receiving based on three very
real awards that go out to people who
like go into like impoverished areas and
uh make the world a better place and and
I assume it will maybe be you know this
is going to be very early in the movie
might be even a more comedic part
because I wouldn't doubt it the entire
time in the quantum realm steps pretty
serious so maybe the the funnier stuff
in this movie might be in the very early
part before they get sucked in the
quantum realm but like you don't think
there's a comedy store in the clowning
well and they're like yeah it's crazy we
got Louis CK dude right okay oh no
they're still booking in the quantum
realm yeah the quantum realm
cancellations are nine years behind and
wow you should see what Cosby says down
there Hello darling
um but real quick I do think like the
most obvious is yeah they they blow up
like one grain of rice to be able to
feed a whole village or whatever what
are you think some other ways Pim
particles could Advance humanitarian
efforts I mean it'd be great if they
could take everyone's waste human waste
and shrink it down in a tiny size even
nuclear waste right right
we've seen from Darren cross in the
first movie you don't want to only
shrink part of you with a pet particle
that's true I was thinking what if they
made like a giant cow but then I was
like what if that giant cow starts
stomping around and what if it farts
hole in the ozone yeah it's so much
methane methane as the people in the UK
Sam yeah aluminum aluminum advertisement
uh we also learned uh that Hank Janet
and hope will be separated from Scott
and Cassie at some point in the quantum
realm that kind of makes sense because
don't when we see Janet kind of uh
piloting that big Stingray looking
monster it's Hank and hope are on there
with her right and then uh some of the
other scenes we you could tell that it's
Scott and Cassie together including we
didn't get this again in the um the
trailer from last night but my favorite
moment from that first trailer is just
the long shot on on Cassie's helmet
she's just like kind of like reacting to
something you know the second I'm
talking about but it does feel like you
know the group split up maybe uh this
might be more of a father-daughter kind
of story that way we also get two father
daughters Yeah well yeah the press
release they did really harp on the idea
like this is a story about like the
secrets we keep from our families and
the people in your life and like how
well you really know each other and like
the lost time because all of these
groups have like time lost that has
created these barriers between them and
they think they know the other person
but the other person has had their own
experiences without without each other
and so breaking down those walls I hope
Peyton Reed has the foresight to go
James Gunn on this soundtrack and have
Daughter by Pearl Jam and fathers Be
Good to Your Daughters by John Mayer oh
okay all playing during the quantum
realm explorations of the Father God
again
or dance with my father again I think
there's a song called Butterfly Kisses
uh
uh condominium producer Stephen brassard
also gave a very interesting quote about
the scale of this movie and we've talked
about this a little bit before how this
seems to be setting up to be a very
different kind of Ant-Man movie he
compared the film to Captain America
Winter Soldier and Captain America Civil
War saying it really felt like the
future of the MCU is going to be defined
by the action of those films we really
like the idea of making this Ant-Man
film as important and integral to the
MCU going forward like this is not just
a little throwaway fun comedy superhero
movie uh this is gonna be big this is a
game changer I love it that like the
first two movies were kind of they were
fun they were enjoyable they introduced
some overall important technology but
they certainly weren't like you got to
hang your hat on the MCU with these two
movies and now this movie all of a
sudden out of nowhere the third in the
franchise I guess not to similar to Thor
Ragnarok it just is like it's
magnifying no pun intended the uh the
importance of Ant-Man in the MCU and the
Ant characters when Tommy you made a
great point last night that you know
this is the one where they got to set
the tone yeah for phase five but also
for like Kang like we saw he who remains
it's not really a king right a
difference he instantly died basically
right this is like and they can't kill a
king in every movie and still have
another king that's fine but like this
is the one where like he can do some
awful things that have like wide
reaching effects uh and you know really
freak people out yeah freak them out
yeah this has got to be our new Thanos
they gotta they gotta give him some
gravitas
um so we also got some character
District descriptions of of some new
characters in this film including
there's some really interesting ones at
the end they're all interesting but uh
just hold hold your horses yeah so we
get through all these so um now we
haven't heard this said out loud in a in
a trailer so I don't know exactly how to
pronounce this character's name but I'm
going to say gentora wrong
and we have seen her I don't know if we
saw her in the most recent trailer we
did see her in the first trailer she's
one of those kind of three-pointers like
yeah yeah uh character she's the leader
of the Freedom Fighters a group of
displaced inhabitants in the quantum
realm whose lives were turned upside
down by Kang I assume this is the war
that's taking place when they arrive
right I don't love that name Freedom
Fighters don't tell Kane your name is
Freedom Fighters remember the name like
the king okay
what was the name of the people that
fought in uh uh Falcon on the Winter
Soldier uh flag Smashers flag Smashers
okay I was like I thought they were the
Freedom Fighter
is also a silly name in my opinion let's
play comic book released all the flag
smashes you also know uh Fabric's not
something you usually think about smash
yeah let's be honest that's a folding
kind of thing you smash beer cans okay
you Smash Bros
that's right super uh
chatura is played by actress Katie
O'Brien who um if yeah she's like a
really jacked MMA fighter kind of
um actor actress uh and and she was
quoted as saying there are living beings
in this world and gentura is a native
you'll get to explore a lot of the
different colonies the different groups
of people that we have here and then she
says this broccoli man is my personal
favorite I love that there's somebody
called broccoli man I don't know if
that's just like the lingo they used on
the set to describe
his weapon is throwing James Bonds but
at least like a floor what's Groot like
yeah what if he's like a floor Colossus
but he's like just like underdeveloped
yeah I mean well probably a member of
the Brassica family with Asian Brussels
sprout and senorita kale
on Jess's birthday how could you How
Could You General Stephen P cauliflower
yeah that's right uh she says we have
characters that float we have blobs we
have mind readers all kinds of zany
creatures and humanoids and mysterious
things which is she describing a circus
well it doesn't remind me of you you
just referenced Thor Ragnarok right he
lands on uh the car that's a car and
there's all kinds of wide variety of
characters not a lot of prophylactics
though hello scar welcome to the MCU
Hulk's out there raw dogging
she's pinching me
we also uh we learned a bit more about
Bill Murray's character Lord krylar uh
he is the governor of Axia a high status
Community within the quantum realm he
also owns a huge pleasure yacht he and
Janet are old acquaintances and real
quick Lord krylar does show up in the
comics one issue of like the amazing uh
or the Incredible Hulk from like the
late 70s early 80s it did play a
character from The microverse which is
kind of comic book equivalent to Quantum
realm ooh like dies in in the first step
first issue that he appears in so I
doubt there's a whole lot of connection
they probably just picked a name before
I I so last night I spent a little time
obsessing over this trailer and these
and this in this press kit and I tried
to unscramble the name Lord krylar too
like a human Earthling name and Daryl
you can make the first name Daryl out of
it you can also make Carl but then the
last name kind of plot it's like Daryl
Claude or something like that because
I'm like I just want him to be a guy who
was like like a like a DirecTV dish
installer that got sucked into the
quantum Realm by accident and now he's
like reinvented himself as Lord kylar by
scrambling up his name it's a little
Voldemort ask maybe but wouldn't that be
fun if it's just that he's like a
MacGuffin or it's all like a Rouge that
he's well and Bill Murray has been
quoted as saying he's a bad guy we know
we already got Kang we already got Modoc
that's if Bill Murray's also a bad guy
we got three potentially antagonists for
Our Heroes I like that Bill Murray's
probably the because it seems like he's
from a richer community that he's a bad
guy in the form of like a rich man
that's just like yeah I gave King what
he wanted so he would leave me and my
rich folks alone yeah I think he's a bad
guy in the way that stranger things
always has a like Carrie always was like
the evil corrupt mayor Matthew Modine in
the first season was like the bad guy
scientist but then there's also like a
very powerful monster that's way more
powerful so or way more way more
threatening rather so I have a feeling
Bill Murray is like Bill Murray is the
mayor and I like what Jessica's saying
also every zombie movie right usually
has like the guy who sells out his
fellow survivors not me yeah well and
especially if he has a history with
Janet maybe there's a little resentment
there right maybe it's not a positive
history she was in there for decades but
we don't know what decades is like in
the quantum realm so I'm sure in that
100 years she got on that pleasure yeah
she may have helped King at some point
not knowing like what he was capable of
interesting that'd be [ __ ] up if she
got into sorry effed up if I already
said it whatever you said it's not even
325 demonetized no it was my birthday
tell YouTube
um but if she got on the pleasure oh my
God it's oh gosh oh gosh now you guys
got me nervous about cursing
um but if she got on the pleasure yacht
and then that's how she conceived what
we don't know if she has a baby yet she
took the pee out to f-town is what
you're saying whoa you think she could
have some kids a p yacht so how are you
on the P yacht not going to f-town yeah
could Jen Torah be her daughter
causing a conflict between hope and
gentura I like that idea well okay two
other characters we found out about and
one of these we we knew a little bit so
we knew William Jackson Harper had been
cast in this of uh Chidi from the good
place uh also from mid-somer and and
other things
um he's playing a character called quas
yeah hell yeah so we know is from the
quantum realm when he's Called Quest
some people think it might be Quasar
who's like a character who's kind of
associated with this whole uh area of
the Marvel Comics so possibly playing
Quasar and again we could be he's a
known actor so that might he might be a
significant role but or maybe this movie
is just stacked deep with people you
recognize was like an unnamed Soldier
and uh kind of forever I mean she had a
name but like she was in for four
minutes hey she can't expect to get too
big of a woman
Lake Bell can do whatever she wants look
up how to Make It in America okay guys
I'm just saying Google Lake though okay
it's a TV show
uh and then this is some of the weirdest
detail David desmalkian who of course
was in Scott Lang's crew in the first
two movies he's playing a new character
called veb uh no details on who that
character who those characters are but
we assume you know there may be somebody
in the quantum realm so you know is this
I'm gonna guess he's like a CGI
character that David has now came it's
just voicing give me that light head
person we've seen yeah or you could be
the bartender why did they show the
bartender and also you know David Des
mocking used a pretty thick accent in
the first two movies so maybe he uses
just kind of like more of an American or
a standard accent in this it's
unrecognizable but Peyton Reed who's
like I want to get him in there I like
this guy what a stupid example is he
probably going to be playing a character
where they're like oh let me play
something that's more comfortable to
your liking and then they exhume examine
his brain or something and he's like
here's a voice that you're comfortable
with knowing and it's a monster playing
that voice yeah
that's sometimes how they just throw
people home I like that now do we think
Michael opinion might show up in some
ways it would be a great surprise reveal
yeah I'm gonna guess T.I does not no
probably he's too busy doing his own
investigations hey
uh but maybe maybe it might open you
maybe get his Integrity voice acting
something like that again he's an
important part of the series
um okay so we have again a very
interesting display of art coming later
in the show
I want to mention before we get into our
ads guys it's Jessica's birthday yeah if
you want to venmo her at Tommy pixels or
use my new cash app checking
we are just powered by Russian Uh
Russian uh deep dark web uh websites you
can cash app you can chaching me uh you
won't give me the money at tommyboy69
420. what does Wired Magazine say about
cha-ching oh yeah Wired Magazine says no
no no no no no no no no no do not do not
put your money in that app unless you're
nasty we are we are getting a lot of
super chats uh we should get to those
here in a second especially a lot saying
happy birthday to Jessica and lots of
great questions uh but first we gotta
pay the bills folks that's right we
gotta talk about our great sponsors
today I'm trying to save some money in
2020. I'm going to Vegas next weekend
trying to see Frank Ocean at Coachella
folks I care for blackpink and DJ Ramos
which is a name I just made up but I bet
you didn't know that uh and a great way
to save a little money is to use this
great app called upside uh which you can
use when you're buying gas groceries or
dining out any of those things with
upside you can get cash back on your
purchases you make every day they
usually your purchases you're going to
make anyways it's basically cash back
for just doing you folks upside even
offsets inflated prices they're giving
you cash back on purchases it's also
super easy to use I gotta say I I use
the the upside app all the time anytime
I need gas in my car check that app see
like what gas station around me is
offering a good deal and I go to that
gas station I save a bunch of money yeah
yeah and right now if you download the
free upside app use our promo code break
room all one word break room you get an
extra 25 cents back for every gallon of
gas on your first tank of gas that you
get with them uh like like we said it's
really easy it's an app you claim they
offer in the app you go you do your
thing you pay as usual with your credit
your debit card and then the app will
tell you how you get your reward uh you
can earn three times more cash back with
upside than most Credit Card Rewards or
loyalty programs plus upside doesn't
sell your personal information to third
parties what it'll never show up on
cha-ching upside users are earning
hundreds of dollars a year they have a
great rating in the App Store 4.8 Stars
no Bragging but that's pretty good folks
as Jay pointed out yesterday someone
very Petty refused to give them
lifestyle it's like when your Uber
rating is 4.9 you're like what driver
yeah I thought I smelled you just have
to save money I guess I use it all the
time when it's like oh we're gonna go
out tonight I don't know I don't know I
just find a place in the app to go out
to eat it makes that decision even
easier so download the free upside app
and use promo code break room that's
promo code break room to get an extra 25
cents back for every gallon on your
first time trying to save your money out
here folks speaking of saving money oh
let me tell you are you like me for your
sake I hope not I want to let you know
about a sponsor I really appreciate
that's hellofresh eating well is at the
top of my mind this month it's no secret
I've set my New Year's resolution fit on
every ride at Universal Studios
Hollywood and where the fairies classic
iconic sweatshirt okay and neither of
those are happening without hellofresh
it's comforting to know you always get
top quality with hello fresh hello fresh
makes dinner time easy peasy with fresh
and Fast and Furious recipes hello fresh
questions oh hello fresh also has a line
of delicious filling meals that are
ready in less than 15 minutes enjoy
tasting quality Done Quick with recipes
like Sesame beef tacos Thai spiced pork
meatballs or their winner winner orzo
chicken dinner meal or for me I do a
loser loser chicken snoozer meal here at
break room love hellofresh and as I've
said before I used to feed a family of
three with them now I feed a family of
one I love fresh that's America's number
one meal kit for people struggling and
people thriving
for yourself go to hellofresh.com break
room that's right you gotta use break
room 22 use the code break room 22 for
22 free meals plus shipping for me
that's two to three days where the
hellofresh meals for the rest of the
world a solid week that's hellofresh.com
slash break room 22 and if you don't use
the code I'll come to your house use the
code break room 22 it's time for the
discussion okay what if they want you to
come to their house if you want me to
come to your house and cook for you I
will because I miss people eating oh
Tommy I hate eating alone well I refuse
Jessica makes me eat in front of her but
she hides behind a curtain makes me mean
hi guys
chew on your food piggy boy
Happy Birthday Jessica another year of
that don't out me like that I don't know
sometimes she hits me all right now
and I like it when she does last night
we got a brand spanking new trailer for
Ant Man in The Wasp you guys all saw
Quantum Mania we were watching that
riveting football game oh boy thank God
that trailer came out because otherwise
there'll be a night I'd love to forget
the football game yeah that game was
awful but yeah I was on the horny toads
I did I was toting I put a load on the
toad and let me tell you now I'm not
eating my ice cream out of the mode yeah
you got you got scorned by the horn yeah
yeah
those toads went chode mode on me all
right now anyway let's get back to the
trailer packed full of new details we've
got a much better idea of what our
version of Kang is gonna go like God
this red light is really making my head
dance much better idea what this version
of Kang will look like our first look at
Modoc more on him later now I feel like
you're messing with me Cassie's in jail
a whole lot of Scots which has us asking
that's a deal with all these different
Ant-Man yeah yeah what is the deal we
see Scott spinning splitting into two
multiple times okay we see Scott
splitting into two multiple times in the
trailer suppose we see a full-on Ant-Man
swarm you guys do we think these
different Scots are one of the following
things and I'll get into each one in
specific detail because your boy was up
late doing homework last night are these
Scots variants you know uh like we saw
in Loki you know which are basically
like mistakes or accidental timeline
breaches off of the Sacred timeline
created by he who remains R.I.P
rest in uh in this uh side effect of the
quantum Nexus which as we know is the
point in the quantum realm where reality
begins to distort things fold in on
themselves uh cheese folds in like on
shit's creek or is it multiversal
incursions like we saw in mom Multiverse
of Madness the time to maximoff thinks
it might be that or is this just Kane
being a little stinker interesting this
all could be king be a little stinker
now let's break it down here let's go
with the first one we have the variance
we know
obviously our introduction to akang not
the king in this movie he who remains
was in Loki season one with the TVA we
saw that there are all these variants of
Loki that don't necessarily even have to
be Tom Hiddleston Loki right we have
Sylvie we have a freaking alligator
we've got uh Richard uh Grant hello
we've got both foloki we've got kid Loki
we've got present Loki which is Tom
Hiddleston so it's a little bit of me
contradicting myself you guys think
these are variants these Scots well so
that's interesting in that in the
trailer they all look exactly like Paul
red right they're no alligator or
ant-man's or or female ant-mans that we
saw right so like that would seem to be
evidence that it's not variance right
they're and their their costumes are all
the same too it's like and we physically
see one split into two yeah which is not
what happens in Loki obviously right um
but now that would mean if they're
variants and not some things we're going
to talk about that would mean they're
all 616 Ant-Man right right like
different timelines but saying
Multiverse but the variants are all on
the same sacred timeline the multiversal
incursions are the different versions so
I think you know sorry to cut you off
the the different Scots the fact they
look the same does still play into the
fact that they could be variants because
the a variant can be formed just by
someone doing something that goes
against a sacred timeline so Scott could
be reacting in a way that is not planned
by he who remains and therefore another
copy of Scott is branching out into that
new timeline okay and this is the one
place in the universe where you see it
happen in the moment and you instantly
split off and become another one of you
exactly and so do you think the reason
we see so many Ant-Man that they can
like pile up is maybe Scott does that on
purpose well I'm wondering if he kind of
uses his ability to control ants maybe
he knows that he can kind of like
influence the suit as well or or maybe I
mean like this is crazy but maybe
they're like uh uh like how Iron Man Has
like the drones the Drone versions
environment maybe these are just like
Ant-Man drones that we don't even know
about the queen that we're gonna find it
yeah maybe maybe there's something like
that it's interesting maybe these are
just a bunch of Ant-Man suits that can
move around and and I feel like there
are two important shots in that trailer
uh one of which was in the previous
trailer too right we see multiple
Ant-Man running in the same direction
including the giant man that turns into
spaghetti right and then there's the
other moment where Scott seems to uh
seems to be getting almost swallowed up
by the hands the bodies of a bunch of
other see in this one when they're piled
up they seem to be collaborating that's
like real ants when they make a little
Bridge with their bodies or we saw this
at like the first they seem to be
working together there I guess though
they could be climbing on top of each
other trying to be the one Ant-Man that
reaches the top and they're stepping on
each other's heads or whatever or
they're collaborating to try to win for
all of the Ant-Man but that movement
which is getting swallowed up and he
says doesn't he say out loud I'm sorry
Cassie well it's hard to tell if that's
something he's saying in that moment if
that line is
yard also they love to trick or trick us
with that kind of stuff and it could be
he it's not that he's being swallowed it
could be that structurally it's not
holding right like maybe it's like oh we
were so close to getting out of the pit
and then we didn't you know like we're
so close to reaching this thing and then
it collapsed all right so let's talk
about the side effect of the quantum
Nexus possibility now the quantum Nexus
like all Nexus points is like a chaotic
point where reality can be bent and
scared I think that they're in the
quantum Nexus and that's why we see
giant man uh turning into a a string
cheese I think you know we saw in
Infinity War Thanos does that to
um mantis yeah I'm obviously a
Multiverse of Madness we saw uh we saw
uh Mr Fantastic very famously get turned
into uh something less fancy something a
little less fantastic uh and you made a
great Point Tommy with those earlier in
the office where you were saying both
those moments are driven by Red kind of
like chaos Magic from Wanda but reality
stone work from uh Thanos yes now like
Wanda's powered by like the Mind Stone
but she has chaos magic which often
presents itself as like reddish so this
could all be like fuel this power that
the reality Stone has could be fueled by
like the Nexus right that's what I I'm
wondering I'm wondering you know we
brought up yesterday and it seems to
make more sense to me now uh as the more
the more we kind of watch the trailer
and go over it if these if the Infinity
Stones were smashed to atoms and
specifically that language was used by
Thanos if they have sprinkled into the
quantum Realms
Amber goldish Lighting in it there's
obviously the blue there's the red I'm
sure if we go back and look there's
there's some green in there there
appears to be infinity stone color
elements obviously colors are very
important to Marvel go to an Mt video
check it out the man has endless endless
research and theories on it that are all
I think kind of supporting this so it
does to me seem like maybe there is some
infinity stone power going on in the
quantum realm now Brandon we've been
talking about this at a certain point
the Multiverse has to come into play in
these movies at the same time as the TVA
and sacred timeline we have branched
timelines we have a Multiverse we
haven't really seen them combined in
something Multiverse of Madness was
strictly about different Doctor
Strange's from different and different
wandas from different universes yeah no
mention of timelines in that movie
exactly it wasn't like oh the it made a
very distinct thing like this is a
completely other Earth Earth a3a that is
different from eight or six one six so
there's our main one that's where we had
Dr fantastic Captain Britain and all
those people so so it's like is this how
are they is there a way they can get the
Multiverse into the quantum realm does
that make any sense and that this would
be the argument that all those Scots we
see that is a million Scots sent by a
million Kings all to do the same thing
or achieve the same I love that player I
think heavy spoilers mentioned that in
in their video was like there is the
possibility that this is just like tons
of kings are sending tons of Scots from
everywhere to all get the same item and
they're all like in a mad mad mad world
it's a live-action like Fall Guys video
games yeah there's a bunch of people
racing at once or that game PC game
Lemmings which although the Lemmings
video Is tragically a it's a work if you
guys do research on the Lemmings walking
out the side of it so they were coaxed
into it it's a myth they were promised
an orgy at the bottom of that cliff
and for me I gotta say there's been
times in my life I'd walk off a cliff
for a little bit of action all right now
finally option D I think I don't know
is this something King is doing guys and
so that could include this is like an
illusion yeah some kind of trippy thing
that he's a
mysterio-esque kind of thing that he's
putting Scott through what else could
King be doing in these scenes I think
that uh okay and I talk about this on
inside Marvel so go watch inside Marvel
when it drops uh and watch it anyway
because I oh yeah watch it anyways so I
think what's gonna happen is they're
gonna try duping
um Kang and there's no way you can dupe
King that sounds stupid I know but my
nickname in high school you know him
Duke Kern
squared so they I think they're trying
to do King and I think that orb that
we're seeing might have something to do
with how Janet Hank and
um hope are at and I think her them all
climbing each other to get to him is to
stop him from actually leaving out of it
I think the entire all we're seeing of
multiples of Scott are all Illusions
created by Kang so it when hope goes in
there she's like I don't know which one
to grab because I don't see ours and
when he's climbing to the top to get to
it she's reaching and they're trying to
stop him and pull him in and I think and
I don't think it is ADR I think him
saying I'm sorry Cassie is a part of
like I tried to redeem myself I tried to
get back over on him and it's not
working
um I also essentially think Cassie is
going to be the first one to die so
that's probably
oh that's a huge prediction
do we all agree whatever whatever the
reason for all these Scots is and and
whatever McGuffin whatever those rings
represent uh whatever that is
Kang's goal is to get out and yeah he
wants to get out into the normal world
so that he can conquer the 616 uh that
we know and love do we think that's it I
I don't yeah I mean I think that that is
his main goal I also wonder if that
round the actual Nexus or the quantum
Nexus is a little bit of known
Interstellar logic that like if the
longer you're down there even in the
quantum realm time moves different you
know what I mean that could be like
Scott's failure setting up like that
could be why Kang one like he Kane could
be tricking him to go down there to
eliminate Ant-Man he may see that the
Pim technology and ant-man's like
wielding of it is the one thing that
could kind of stop him and he's like let
me get him down there yeah and then he's
stuck down there and time is moving
differently there's the theory right
that like though the first trailer
especially made it seem like the whole
Pim Lang family got sucked in kind of a
Honey I Shrunk the Kids kind of
accidental way but like that it's not an
accident okay is somehow forcefully
pulling them summoning them whatever
that might be I think you're right
though ultimately the goal I think Kang
and then he's going to take modoc's
little hand and get them out of there
and then I think Kang is going to start
restart aim uh with a puppet Aldrich
Killian type character who is actually
just another Kang or something like that
oh yeah we get the Council of Kings
go watch inside Marvel
the same thing that we talked about
inside and inside Marvel we talk about
this too also
on Thursday watch this episode today if
you want more on Modoc watch our Channel
we have a Modoc video coming out tonight
I mean now we already talked about Scott
having uh does 616 Scott have the
ability to control these duplicates it
does seem like he can at least get him
to work together so either by Cult like
Charisma or actual mind control
uh you know do we think do we think the
TVA might show up if these are timeline
things yeah could we see uh I think they
got I mean I don't know maybe since this
is the first
film of phase five right technically
maybe they won't quite break it in but
it's like it's only a matter of time
before you have to have TVA and and
multiversal themes coming into
everything right
I don't think they can reach the quantum
realm it's kind of hard to get into it
and so that's and he's trapped in it and
if he is banished there by he who
remains though there's no we way anyone
else can get out yeah and and it seems
the quantum realm seems special right
like it takes very specific technology
to get there and apparently it's
impossible to get out right at least for
Kang one of the most powerful creatures
and you know in existence or whatever
um yeah that's interesting uh why do we
think that giant man is getting turned
into spaghetti I think that that is just
a product I honestly or my just simply
the the quantum Nexus reality just it
reacts strange there I think that like
the longer you're there the more
unstable the the atoms in your own body
might become probably if you're
increasing or decreasing in size of that
it maybe even triggers kind of a defense
mechanism from the realm itself like
from the Nexus point itself where it's
like I don't like this I don't want any
weird I don't want incursions I don't
want very like like maybe they're almost
Flying Too Close to the side except for
instead of burning up you can you know
you're using remembering uh Hawkeye how
they had the pemtech uh arrows what if
there is a part of the uh equipment that
they do have that they're destroying
each of them if my theory is right and
these are all just Illusions created by
King if uh the pims Hannah Janet Janet
Janet Hope and Hank are destroying them
with the technology that they do have
and they die in different ways one
string one's dust one I like that
because again we see those in that shot
we see those Scots running the same
direction they could be racing each
other yeah they're not necessarily
working together and so that could be
like yeah kind of sniper style Hank and
and hope and whoever are kind of picking
off these alternate oh yeah alternate
Scots to help their Scott win the race
right yeah guys I told you guys geez Tom
you've been talking a lot in this
episode maybe let someone else talk too
bad it's time for mandatory fun
we love it when you talk a lot Tommy uh
yeah I know but you know I always feel
like the more my voice gets out the more
people want to shout hey what is he
talking about now it's mandatory fun and
it's Jessica's birthday so we're gonna
play the graphic again hey
I didn't want to play it again now
uh Jessica says no more graphic play the
play The Thirsty thespian
not even uh show us the Ant-Man
John's hold no stop but you're not gonna
play any more Graphics
there we go somebody stole the agency in
my team
yeah by the way if you took her HDMI
cable return it uh we're in Winnipeg and
uh
let's focus up here guys the animal the
Animaniac the quantumania trailer blew
our socks off with so much new footage
we got Modoc more Kang and lots of
different men and men there was one
thing that really stuck with us though
huh and that was Kang going all Seth
Rollins and curb stomping Ant-Man and
breaking his mask that was terrible no
we hear spelled incorrectly by me at the
break room I spelled here like hearing
it's okay they didn't know they didn't
know unless you told them they would
tell you this you say this right now
a classically smart person I can
memorize things but I cannot write and
you're getting math here at the break
room thank you Jessica are men and women
of Peace wait what are we hearing
we're hearing a message
Happy Birthday Jessica you're 18 years
old today anyway we're here at break
room are women and men of Peace so we
decided we're gonna build back in the
wake of King's destruction and we're
gonna make our own Ant-Man masks and
these will be displayed in our break
room art gallery for peace and
prosperity for all of the year so that
the new rockstars employees new and old
can see the precious art that we made
now let's take turns I think Brandon you
gotta go first like unlike what we saw
on the trackers we were so disturbed by
these will not get smashed at all yeah
no these are going to be they're going
to be on display yeah these are
important art effects
look at that
Brandon made this man this is Ant-Man
Prime today these are not being smashed
guys because these are art this is Art
I'll be honest it's made out of a prime
box we've weird man Prime we vetoed this
before but like Willy Wonka I've been
begging us to open the studio up to fans
we might let some fans come in and see
these masks yeah these are that's how
special they are Jessica do you want to
show yours last because it's your
birthday because mine's better oh Tommy
has to start with yours
Brandon's it's both named Prime because
it's a prime box but also kind of has an
Optimus Prime mine is called uh Postman
loan it's a post Malone tribute with
some foam there's some bugs on top he
has post Malone's trademark always tired
tattoos under his eye he also he also
has a teardrop tattoo implying that he's
witnessed the murder it's under the
witness High not the committed eye
that's good wow okay Jessica said she
wants to go last okay mine's right here
oh okay great yeah Jessica is a great
one okay beautiful again Guys these are
going to be displayed for the rest of
the Year this is my handmaid's tale
wowmate's tail I no Tommy said we could
make a mess for anything okay
okay well the bus just ran over me a bit
it's your birthday and then I actually
didn't have time to make one but I I
found one you found one yeah somebody
else in the office must have made one so
I'm just kind of gonna show it I don't
know it's very minimalist what does it
say Wow
I have a secret oh interesting oh my God
I know it's not really well we can't do
that because we are not gonna smash that
no I get it yeah we are not gonna I'm
like these will be safe forever yeah but
I I don't know it does feel like
somebody whoever left this or wanted it
should step on it
we're gonna smash the ones that we
actually worked on yeah I also don't
think I can oh
hey something just came out of it what
is
what is secret you're fired
Rosebud no it says
oh there's something inside wait there's
another oh there's
what's happening the best it's taped to
itself the best the best 2023 Marvel
movie will be okay oh and then there's
another thing inside wow
we really were undersold on this side
morbius two still more
no I don't know what that is wait a
second you found that
here you can have wow that's crazy
inside of a red bug I mean Jessica is
your birthday I guess you can't
I worked very hard on that I don't think
oh
oh my God Brandon it's only fair smash
hers right I can't do it smash her
because I don't think the view of a wife
neither of you you have to smash the
matriarchy neither of you have to win if
we all lose I'm just saying uh oh my God
yeah if all of us lose
oh my god oh no oh no
oh
whoa fine oh fine okay but we're not
gonna smash time
if all of us lose then none of us win
and I've got a celebrity Smasher what
Wendy
is that Kang's music ladies and
gentlemen smash variant
Whitney man letting him we'll be we'll
be smashing my post-mat loan you got to
put him on the white guy
right right there will be great there
you go there you go
careful don't fall whoa look at those
ladies and gentlemen so sorry we will
never let you losers thank you Whitney
the art gallery is closed for business
oh that's what we're so happy mandatory
we want to shout out some of the folks
uh sending in super chats David Z saying
happy birthday Jess thank you thank you
David Z Grant Hill loved to work with
the Phoenix Suns in the Orlando Magic uh
no uh do you think there's a connection
between the orange and blue energy of
the ten rings and the orange energy of
he who remains in the blue of quantum I
was thinking that when you see those
kind of rings
foreignification is a real thing so when
the atoms of your body are stretched
when in proximity of massive
gravitational force like a black hole
you get slurped up by The Singularity
our good friend Chrissy coming in guys
look at how sad Brandon is right now I
mean that's kind of like Ant-Man after
the helmet gets done the gallery was
gonna be huge I'm so devastated we're
gonna have to do another arcade I
promise we weren't smashing I like floor
you swore to me our good friend TD Jones
coming in with a good thought here with
previously thought deceased people
showing up in the quantum realm I think
he's referring to we think modak is
gonna be uh Darren cross there uh does
anyone think we have a Wanda sighting he
also throws in a happy birthday Jazz
thank you
um no wonder I'm low on Wanda for this
one I'm good without it only people that
have been shrunken into goo might show
up in one of the flush guys in there oh
the guy Frank poor Frank he's in the
pipes
uh coach walk pointing out that the
weird Phantom Miss minutes account that
is yet to be confirmed that it's run by
Disney or anything like that was
tweeting out the trailer we need to do a
video on that or talk about it
investigation if we need a full load of
investigation and you know what I always
say we thank coach walk for giving us
coach run and Coach run for giving us
coach fly uh also Tommy uh that uh Miss
minutes Twitter account yeah she
followed the costume she follows the
beauty of the Beast because they have
the crossover event of the century what
is it again uh cogsworth destroys Miss
minutes gears
cogsworth's grandfather clock hands
human again oh he's human again you look
lovely today I will destroy you with my
minute hand okay and I'll use my hour
ain't no one minute hand hey oh uh break
the clock show me what you got I don't
want no one minute hand to break me off
show me what you got
I'm sure I butchered your name uh yeah I
know he's got a great jumper uh Kang
doesn't want to come near the golden uh
sphere because he's afraid of his
variants I like that as an idea of like
that's the reason all these Kings send
all these Scots because the kangs don't
want to run into other kings that's a
really interesting Theory they don't
like each other no and they know that
they kill each other uh John Wright
sending in a Super Chat do you think
there is a realm within the quantum I
mean it's called The Shadow realm well
don't you talk to me but it's also uh
very Rick and Morty is because there is
an episode where they have a mini verse
in a mini version a mini version inside
of car so and I wouldn't be surprised if
the writers of Rick and Morty that are
now riding basically the MCU were like
yeah we can do that well and it stands
to reason that the further science you
know in our world we always think we
find the smallest thing and there's
something smaller so if there is a small
thing there's another smaller thing
there's a smaller King inside of a
universe that can created within the
quantum realm oh he's Queen Queen he's
Queen Chanel standing in a Super Chat
Bucky Barnes ATL free girl thank you all
xenix uh saying uh uh they didn't write
the name of Earl of pew pew pew puke
puke
uh pointing out that some people are
criticizing the CGI in these trailers I
thought it looked incredible
is mad about Modoc but there is no way
he was ridiculous in the comics he's
gonna look ridiculous here it's a Giant
floating head yeah what do you guys want
his face small and head big did he want
them to cast a real floating head yeah
is that what you want I mean and we also
know they're still tweaking stuff like
they've added there are shots in this
trailer that are kind of in earlier
Trails where they've put in more stuff
we see this with every moment that's the
thing I feel like with Modoc that was
the one that you guys don't need to fix
because keep him ridiculous it should
look silly she-hulk's different this is
like oh he is silly because he's the
craziest looking Villain Like keep him
yeah guys if you want my thoughts please
send it to Chang over to my account
16 exclamation points one hashtag thank
you before we get out of here thank you
to ajb uh bandana b310 Evan Ebenezer
splooge yes we love the GSU DJ gold gun
that's not your name DJ Jasmine Victor
Boogie's World Christian our good friend
Christian unpronounceable uh and uh and
everybody else that was in the chat and
enjoying uh the show today we appreciate
you we're gonna there's again as Tommy
pointed out much more Ant-Man coverage
on our Channel including a Modoc video
that should be dropping very soon
Jessica's going to be in an inside
Marvel episode on Thursday tomorrow or
uh yeah tomorrow we'll have a full
trailer breakdown out that yeah she's
hosting I put a lot of work into that
one as well so lots of Ant-Man on the
channel this weekend he's got a video
about Cassie coming out later this week
so and I'm very excited to announce I've
been leaving a plate full of crumbs next
to my bed every night to harness the
power of ants in my own person
I don't like that for you
yeah you are a roadster guy me I'm just
a rat king
you want to see what time
it's her birthday all right uh we thank
you all for watching we we all wish
Jessica the happiest of birthdays happy
birthday to our Queen thank you guys for
letting me stomp on your pieces it's
actually letting you at all
so you'll step on me yeah I'm doing it
for free today I'm giving out free
Stomps all right uh come back uh we'll
be back at our normally scheduled time 3
P.M uh Pacific 6 p.m Eastern tomorrow uh
sometimes 305 sharp uh everybody have a
great day keep your Gucci to moochi
everybody
it's true
[Music]